Depuis plus de 150 millions d'années,
les tortues peuplent nos océans.
Pourtant, aujourd'hui, on estime
que la quasi-totalité des espèces
est menacée ou grandement menacée.
Bonjour à tous, c'est Léa !
Aujourd'hui, je vous emmène
dans un centre de soins pour les tortues
pour comprendre
les menaces qui pèsent sur elles
et pourquoi elles sont le témoin direct
de la pollution plastique dans les océans.
C'est parti.
Nous sommes au CESTMed qui est le
On va pouvoir découvrir
comment elles sont soignées
mais aussi comment
elles vont être relâchées.
C'est parti.
- Toutes les tortues qu'on a,
elles sont prises dans les filets de pêche.
- Ce sont les pêcheurs
qui vous appellent, du coup ?
- Les pêcheurs qui nous appellent,
on est en collaboration avec eux,
ils savent très bien que c'est
une espèce en voie de disparition.
Même si physiquement,
elles ont l'air d'aller bien,
on les prend parce qu'on ne sait jamais.
Elles peuvent avoir du plastique
en elles ou alors un hameçon.
Donc on récupère toutes les tortues marines.
- Il y a quoi comme espèces
dans le centre ?
- Nous, au centre de soins, en 15 ans,
puisque ça fait 15 ans que le CESTMed existe,
on a eu à peu près 500 tortues,
dont, majoritairement,
que des tortues caouannes.
On a eu très, très peu de tortues vertes.
- C'est très répandu
de toute façon comme espèce.
- La tortue caouanne, oui, c'est la plus
répandue en Méditerranée et dans le monde.
Déjà, pour reconnaître une tortue caouanne,
c'est au niveau des écailles frontales.
Donc la tortue caouanne,
elle a 4 écailles frontales.
La tortue verte, par exemple,
elle en a 2.
Donc elle, on voit très bien sur celle-ci
qu'elle en a 4, plus une, voilà.
Ensuite, une tortue caouanne,
quand elle est juvénile,
on peut le remarquer parce que c'est la seule
qui a des petits pics sur les écailles dorsales.
- D'accord, avec le temps, qui se...
- Avec le temps, qui se lissent, voilà.
Plus la carapace est grosse,
plus ça se lisse.
Une tortue caouanne, ça peut faire
jusqu'à 80 kg et 1 mètre, voilà.
Donc c'est la 3ème
tortue marine la plus grosse.
- La première étant... la tortue luth !
- Qui peut faire jusqu'à 2 mètres et 900 kg.
Il y a 7 espèces de tortues marines
dans le monde.
Alors, il y a la tortue imbriquée.
Cette espèce-là, elle disparaît
à cause du braconnage
parce que ça a une très belle carapace,
voilà, pour elle, c'est ça.
On a la tortue à dos plat,
elle, qu’on ne trouve qu’en Australie.
On a la tortue caouanne,
qu’on trouve en Méditerranée.
La tortue verte,
La tortue luth,
qu’on trouve en Méditerranée aussi.
On a la tortue… olivâtre.
D’ailleurs, elle, elle s’appelle olivâtre
parce que sa carapace est couleur olive.
- Oui, celle-là oui. Celle-là, elle est plus
dans l’océan Indien.
C’est ça. Et on a la tortue Kemp.
La tortue Kemp, il me semble
qu’elle ne pond qu’au golfe du Mexique.
- Là, on vient d’aller chercher du poisson,
donc deux types de poissons différents
pour aller nourrir, du coup,
les tortues qui sont dans cette pièce.
- C’est bien de prendre un hareng, déjà.
- Est-ce que tu peux rappeler l’heure qu’il est
pour un petit dej’ non conventionnel ?
- Là, pour Toti, c’est 5 repas par jour
et le premier, c’est à 9h.
Ça, c’est sa partie préférée.
On va essayer de la couper en deux morceaux
parce que ça fait un peu gros pour elle.
Proportionnellement à nous,
c’est comme si on mangeait
un steak de la taille de notre tête.
- Cinq fois par jour.
- Cinq fois par jour !
On peut essayer de lui mettre,
de l’accrocher à la petite tige en fer,
là, si tu veux.
- Du coup, là, tu cherches le contact visuel.
- D'accord.
- C’est un hareng,
ils aiment bien le hareng.
Mais lui, apparemment
il ne mange pas trop, alors...
- Essaye de tout donner pour que...
- J'essaye, voilà...
Elles peuvent tenir
pendant 4 mois sans manger.
- Je ne sais pas si je tiendrais
4 mois sans manger.
Est-ce que tu peux me raconter
l’histoire de cette mini-tortue ?
- En fait, c’est un enfant de 9 ans qui est parti seul
en Guyane, voir sa grand-mère.
Et le dernier jour, avant de partir, il y avait
un chien qui mangeait des œufs de tortue.
Bon, il a essayé de récupérer un œuf
pour, dans sa tête, le sauver.
- Sauvetage quoi.
- Voilà, sauvetage.
Il l’a mis dans son sac à dos
et puis, il l’a laissé là.
Il a pris l’avion, il est rentré en France.
- Il n’a rien dit à personne !
- 9 jours plus tard,
la tortue est sortie de l’œuf.
Ils l’ont emmenée à une clinique vétérinaire
et le vétérinaire a dit :
"Mais c’est une tortue de mer, moi, je ne peux
rien faire, c’est une espèce menacée."
En tant que centre de soins, notre rôle,
c’est de la maintenir en vie,
de la faire grossir un petit peu
et dans quelques semaines,
normalement, un agent de l’État
la ramènera en Guyane.
- Alors ça, c’est la carte spécifique de Toti,
le nombre de repas qu’elle prend par jour,
on voit que ça va jusqu’à 5 repas par jour
et qu’elle prend 1 gramme par jour.
- Et donc c’est une bonne croissance ?
- Oui, c’est normal, c’est bien.
C’est régulier en tout cas.
- D’accord.
Jean-Baptiste, est-ce que tu peux me dire
ce qu’on va faire maintenant ?
- Là, on va regarder un peu la tortue Emma.
- D'accord.
- Voilà, elle a été capturée
il y a quelque temps dans un chalutier
et du coup, elle a été un peu brûlée
sur certains endroits.
- Avec la friction ?
- Avec le filet, voilà, la friction du filet.
Et on va juste contrôler ses petites blessures
qui ont cicatrisé depuis.
On coince nos doigts devant l’écaille nucale
et derrière les écailles caudales, voilà.
Il y avait quelques petites blessures à cet endroit.
- Là, j’en vois une. Ah oui d’accord, là et là.
- Il faut quand même
toujours faire attention au bec
qui peut mordre
et c’est assez tranchant.
Enlever quelques chairs mortes.
- Donc là, tu enlèves, ok.
Elles n’ont pas le même processus
de cicatrisation que nous ?
- Ça cicatrise quand même
beaucoup plus vite que nous.
- D’accord.
- Et surtout, avec peu de risques d’infection.
- Je crois qu’elle n’est pas ravie.
Moi, je trouve ça hyper impressionnant, quand
tu me disais que c’était un truc de routine,
je ne m’attendais pas, quand même,
à ce que ce soient des trous aussi énormes.
- C’est superficiel, parfois, on a carrément
des tortues à qui il manque
un grand morceau de carapace
ou une nageoire.
Donc là, c’est des blessures
beaucoup plus importantes.
On n’a pas l’impression mais
c’est quand même des animaux sauvages
donc ils ont un stress au niveau
de chaque manipulation.
On essaie d’en faire le moins possible.
On va juste la peser.
Elle a perdu un kilo mais elle va
les reprendre très rapidement cet été.
- Les principaux dangers pour une tortue
quand elle est adulte,
ça peut être les hélices des bateaux
qui peuvent leur couper la carapace,
c’est la pollution marine
et les filets de pêche.
- Et est-ce qu’elles ont un prédateur ?
- Naturel ?
Quand elles arrivent à l’âge adulte,
elles ont très, très peu de prédateurs.
En Méditerranée, par exemple,
il n’y a que le requin blanc.
- Toutes les tortues
sont vouées à être relâchées,
c’est aussi pour ça que le centre est là.
Est-ce qu’il y a des exceptions ?
- Il y a quelques exceptions, dont une,
particulièrement, qui est au Seaquarium
donc je vais vous la présenter.
- Juste à côté du coup ?
- Exact !
Voilà, c'est elle.
Cette tortue-là, sa carapace a été coupée
en deux par une hélice de bateau.
En fait, elle avait la tête en bas
et les fesses en l’air, voilà.
Et la kératine, en fait, la carapace
est faite en kératine,
donc la même matière
que nos cheveux et nos ongles,
quand c’est cicatrisé rapidement,
c’est comme nos cicatrices à nous,
c’est moins complet donc
la carapace était plus légère.
Donc ils ont mis deux plombs
derrière la carapace de la tortue marine
pour la stabiliser pour
qu’elle puisse nager et se nourrir.
Le problème, c’est que sa carapace, elle mue.
Donc, il y a des écailles qui s’en vont,
donc les plombs peuvent s’enlever.
Donc cette tortue-là ne peut pas
être relâchée en mer
parce que si on la relâche
et qu’un plomb lâche,
elle est condamnée à rester la tête en bas
et à ne pas pouvoir se nourrir.
- Donc si vous la relâchiez,
ça serait la condamner en fait.
- Voilà.
- Au-delà des soins prodigués aux tortues,
il y a aussi un véritable travail scientifique
qui est effectué au CESTMed.
Du coup, on va partir à la rencontre
de Delphine Gambaiani
qui est  biologiste au CNRS.
Alors du coup Delphine,
en quoi consiste ton travail ?
Ici au centre de soins, on va récupérer
un maximum d’informations
toujours dans un but de conservation,
de protection de l’espèce.
Ces tortues, l’Europe a choisi de les utiliser
comme indicateur de déchets en mer.
Ce qu’elles ingèreraient,
ce qu’on trouve dans leur tractus digestif,
ça serait représentatif de ce qu'il y a en mer.
Et donc nous, on travaille là-dessus.
- D’où viennent tous ces échantillons ?
- C’est des échantillons qui ont été prélevés
lors d’autopsies, donc ce sont des animaux morts
mais aussi sur des animaux vivants avec l’analyse
de leurs selles, de leurs fèces, de leurs crottes.
Les fils, c’est problématique.
- Les fils, tu vois, j’aurais eu tendance à croire
que ce n’était pas forcément une menace
parce que tu te dis que
c’est tellement petit que…
- C’est ce qu’il y a de pire en fait,
les cordes et les fils.
Ça a tendance à faire
des occlusions intestinales en fait.
L’intestin va se ramasser autour
de ce fil et plus rien ne passe.
Et c’est là où ça entraîne la mort de l’animal.
- D'accord.
- Alors, qu’est-ce que
tu vas nous montrer ?
- Là, ce sont les résultats des autopsies
qui ont été faites en 2017 et 2018, dans 4 pays :
on a la France, l’Espagne,
l’Italie et la Grèce.
Et en rouge, vous avez le taux d’ingestion.
Pour le cas de la France,
sur les 38 individus autopsiés,
81 % d’entre eux avaient des déchets
plastique dans le système digestif.
- Et ça fait froid dans le dos
pour l ‘Espagne, du coup.
- Oui, l’Espagne, alors
l’échantillonnage est plus petit,
uniquement 15 individus ont été autopsiés
mais tous avaient des déchets
dans le système digestif.
- L'une des principales menaces
qui pèsent sur les tortues marines,
c’est la pollution au plastique.
Ici, nous sommes à Palavas-les-Flots
pour partir à la rencontre de Thierry Tsagalos
qui va nous expliquer que la Méditerranée
n’échappe pas du tout à ce fléau.
L’Europe, c'est le 2ème plus gros pollueur
de plastique après la Chine
avec 27 millions de tonnes
de plastique par an
dont seulement 1/3 est recyclé.
Donc aujourd’hui, concrètement,
qu’est-ce qu’on peut faire, à notre échelle ?
- Alors Léa, je te propose
de nous lancer un défi,
j’allais dire te lancer mais
me lancer et de nous lancer un défi :
on va essayer pendant 10 minutes
de ramasser un maximum de déchets
pour voir ce que ça peut donner.
- Je vais lancer mon chrono...
- Top ! Allez.
- Petit plastique d’un sandwich...
Je n’ai pas de gants mais
j’aurais bien voulu ramasser ce déchet-là
qui est pourtant un déchet qu’on trouve
énormément : c’est des couches.
- C’est une paille. Ah non, un truc de sucette !
Voilà un mégot qui date de plusieurs années.
- Ah bah voilà.
Donc on a fait 10 minutes.
- 10 minutes et voilà déjà les déchets
dans une plage qui a déjà été nettoyée.
- Je ne pensais sincèrement pas
trouver autant de déchets
et surtout des déchets aussi divers et variés.
On en parlait justement tout à l’heure avec Delphine,
les petits filets de plastique comme ça,
pour les animaux et même pas que
les tortues, c’est très dangereux.
Alors là, je pense qu’on est sur un petit
emballage de sandwich poulet crudités.
Il y a beaucoup de petites serviettes en papier,
il y a aussi beaucoup
d’emballages de glaces ou de gâteaux,
pas mal de gobelets plastique,
de l’alu... Et ça, oui !
Ça, c’est... je pense que c’était l’emballage
d’un sandwich fait maison, malheureusement.
- On va pouvoir tout mettre dans la poubelle
qui est juste là derrière,
puisque ces déchets ont été ramassés
à proximité d’une poubelle.
- Moi, je note quand même que les gens
nous disent que c’est vachement bien,
parce qu’ils nous ont vu ramasser
mais ils ne nous ont pas du tout aidés.
Les océans sont envahis de pollution,
notamment dans 5 zones.
Les déchets sont concentrés dans
ce qu’on appelle des gyres océaniques,
qui sont des tourbillons géants
qui concentrent le plastique au même endroit.
On estime que la plus importante
de ces zones est dans le Pacifique nord.
Pourtant, il se pourrait que la Méditerranée soit
beaucoup plus concentrée en plastique que cette zone.
Après avoir été en soins,
les tortues sont amenées ici.
x
On est à La Grande-Motte, c’est juste
à quelques kilomètres du centre de soins.
C’est un centre de réhabilitation
où elles sont en semi-liberté
x
avant d’être complètement relâchées,
elles ne restent que quelques semaines
et après, c’est la liberté !
Quel est le but exactement de cet endroit ?
- Justement, pour ces tortues qui ont passé
du temps en captivité, en soins,
le but, c’est de les réhabiliter au milieu naturel,
à faire en sorte qu’elles retrouvent
un peu tous ces instincts naturels.
Qu’elles sachent à nouveau
manger du vivant et surtout nager.
Retrouver la musculature qu’elles avaient
avant d’arriver au centre.
- Alors, combien de temps, en moyenne,
on reste ici quand on est une tortue ?
- Elles vont rester en moyenne
deux semaines et elles vont regagner la mer.
Et ça peut être aussi un endroit intéressant
pour des tortues qui ont été hospitalisées,
à qui on a amputé une nageoire par exemple,
ça va être une étape qui va leur permettre
de se réadapter à leur handicap.
- Où est-ce que tu nous emmènes ?
- C’est un endroit qui est plus proche de la mer
et c’est là où on a le plus de chances
d’observer ces tortues
puisqu’elles vont essayer quand même... toujours,
leur instinct les pousse à essayer de rejoindre...
- De se rapprocher de la mer !
- En s’intéressant à cet animal, on va aussi
s’intéresser en général à la mer,
aux océans et on va pouvoir peut-être
faire en sorte que les gens prennent conscience
que c’est quelque chose de vivant et de fragile.
La tortue, ça peut être un symbole
de la protection des océans
et ça va permettre à tout un chacun
d’avoir envie de protéger cet océan.
On entend parler de vraiment beaucoup
de choses, d’émissions, sur le plastique, etc.
Mais, finalement on ne change pas nos habitudes
et ça, c’est le plus long à faire.
- Et ce n’est pas facile, de faire le pas...
- De changer ses habitudes
et de se dire, qu’au final,
on a tous un impact sur la planète
et qu’on a tous la possibilité
de changer quelque chose.